you find that mr depp has proven all the
elements of defamation
answer yes
as against amber heard we the jury award
compensatory damages in the amount of 10
million dollars
as against amber heard
we the jury award punitive damages in
the amount of five million dollars
do you find that ms heard has proven all
the elements of defamation
answer no as against john c depp ii we
the jury award compensatory damages in
the amount of two million dollars
the conclusion of the blockbuster
defamation trial between johnny depp and
amber hur did not disappoint the jury
finding that both hollywood stars
defamed one another with depp emerging
as the big victor johnny depp being
awarded 15 million bucks after jurors
unanimously decided that amber heard
libeled him with actual malice when she
wrote the 2018 washington post op-ed
identifying herself as a victim of
domestic abuse
heard racking up a win on her counter
claim with the jury deciding she was
defamed by debt
agent
who called her abuse allegations a hoax
heard's being awarded 2 million bucks
but is calling the ruling a setback for
women
depp wasn't there to celebrate he was
too busy rocking out in london but he
did release a statement quote
false very serious and criminal
allegations were levied at me via the
media which triggered an endless barrage
of hateful content although no charges
were ever brought against me it had
already traveled around the world twice
within a nanosecond and it had a seismic
impact on my life and my career and six
years later the jury gave me my life
back
i'm truly humbled now we're blessed on
the five to have some sound legal minds
here people that have actually gone to
law school one was even a judge so let's
go to the probably the most legitimate
legal mind here jesse yes
um were you surprised by this verdict
oh he's actually going i'm actually
going to him he said come to me last
night
i said come to me last i have followed
this trial so closely where to begin
well remember what we talked about at
the beginning that how depp was willing
to risk his reputation as a drunk in
order to erase the reputation of being
an abuser so he was willing to lay
everything out there and say i will let
you make fun of me for the pills and
whatever but i'm not an abuser and he
that's what he did kind of like the
russia hoax with trump right you know
they come out they smear you with false
allegations and you never you never get
your reputation back so you have to sue
and that's what the president likes to
do um very similar i haven't followed
this as closely as the sussman trial but
i'd be happy to talk about that you
would yeah okay
we are talking about there in a minute
johnny depp johnny depp used to be this
great actor that could have any role he
wanted to he was this eclectic guy that
did edward scissorhands and these
oddball rolls but pulled it off really
artistically and then he hit pay dirt
when he did these disney films you know
where he played the pirate and that he
was gold he was a made man in hollywood
and she came and destroyed his life and
did something to a bed i heard uh not
really sure the details but apparently
she just got thrashed by his lawyers in
court and when you can afford good
lawyers they'll thrash your opponent and
that's what happens and she was a very
very bad witness and it looks like this
was a correct judgment yeah she did not
come off as appealing shannon i don't
know if she's she probably couldn't even
get the role playing herself in this
trial at this point i feel like the jury
to a lot of them it did not ring true
what she was saying clearly with this
decision they've made i got to tell you
all the things that we cover in the news
and a lot of it's inside baseball in
washington and new york and all these
things when i was with a bunch of
friends in nashville this weekend this
was the number one topic at dinner by
the way this was right after someone
across the uh restaurant pointed to me
and said hey look it's evil shannon
breeze yes it actually happened
but people were absorbed they had
watched this you know so many trials
aren't televised but they were the
consensus at the table was she was
really manipulative and that they didn't
buy it and none of us had been big
johnny depp fans before this started but
once i started to watch the testimony i
thought if i was a juror i haven't seen
every minute of this but i have real
questions about what she's had to say
and now the jury apparently agreed she
now says she's upset about this and she
says i seem to have lost a right i
thought i had as an american to speak
freely and openly so
she is not conceding anything at this
point
well she used the metoo movement and now
she's betrayed the metoo movement you
can't believe all women is basically
what this case is saying judge you were
right from the beginning i'm gonna go
ahead and say that when we first covered
this you said i don't believe that lady
those were your words yes and you turned
out to be vindicated much like mr depp
yes exactly
look here's the bottom line for this
woman to come out and say it's a setback
for women i think she needs to
understand one thing and that is that
what she did was harmful to real victims
of domestic violence and
i'm sorry for saying it again i started
the first domestic violence unit in the
nation i have dealt with battered women
for 30 years as soon as she started it
was clear she was not the victim she was
the abuser and johnny depp had lawyers
who could take her on this camilla
vasquez was right on target with her the
tape recordings where she said johnny
you going to be a baby you're going to
tell everybody i didn't hit you hard
enough it was difficult for this man to
make a decision to put his whole life on
the table but he had nothing to lose and
when they said to him what have you lost
as a result of what she did he said
nothing short of everything and so this
she she tried to promote herself as
being part of the me too movement that
here i am a woman who's being abused and
she said you know the defense was i
didn't know it was we didn't know it was
about johnny depp are you kidding two
years earlier she tried to get a
temporary restraining order against him
and it was in all the newspapers but she
was impossible to believe and i would
tell a jury as a judge if you find that
one witness has falsified as testified
falsely with respect to one fact you are
free to disregard their entire testimony
this woman lied over and over again and
i feel free to say that on television
she lied she was a liar she was the
abuser and he was the victim and let me
just say one more thing for him to take
on this burden which is not only proof
that he was defamed that she was talking
about him but that she was malicious
that jury had to really see right
through her to say she was malicious and
they found for him 10 million
compensatory 5 million punitive punitive
damages that's the punish you amber
heard
for for taking on this guy's life and
destroying his life so you could be part
of the me too movement don't give me
this stuff you know it's a setback for
women you do not represent women you
represent the worst of women who try to
falsely blame men and that's the end of
it there you go you know jessica
two-part question uh
johnny depp obviously was not there was
that a dumb idea or a bold idea in the
sense that maybe he was giving her you
know the f big f u you're stuck in
fairfax i'm in london and you're gonna
lose and the second question is should
joe biden be impeached
answer the first one second one first
i'm gonna not do that i'm gonna go with
the first one and then say whatever i
want um it was
both a bold and a dumb idea at the same
time i thought that it didn't really
have to do with sticking it to amber
heard he obviously his lawyers did that
and he did it through the entire trial
by being so composed and so open and
honest and i wanted to add to what
you were saying originally and what the
judge pointed out he didn't actually
just lay it all bare he talked about
being abused by his mother and that his
mother abused his father as well
and
watching a man and i hate for this to
have to be gendered but it is we talk
about domestic abuse all the time and
it's usually in the context of women but
it is so much harder for a man
especially a man with that kind of
reputation right he's a heart is kate
moss on the stand right and then we're
all going back and looking at pictures
of them together so right to lay that
out there and it reminded me of when
terry crews testified on on capitol hill
and talked about being abused that is
not easy and i hope that that makes us
also more open to considerations of how
much abuse men actually endure in
society both physical and um emotional
and verbal abuse so bold and stupid
because he had fans that were camped out
at that trial people remember that woman
paying 30 thousand dollars every day and
i think that you show up and you say
thank you for supporting me and kind of
completing the arc of the entire trial
um
but i was shocked obviously i'm not a
lawyer that seemed much higher than i
expected i thought that he was going to
win i did not know that it was going to
be 15 million dollars and i will be
interested to see what the first movie
is that he gets cast in you know how
quickly he's able to be rehabilitated at
fox nation special or something i think
that would be
amazing amazing yeah great
great trials of the past i'm your host
johnny depp i love it or pirates you can
do a whole thing on pirates or america i
think we have the budget for it you
should see what they're paying me at the
fox nation about that yeah yes you know
what is that true last word to jesse
what does this say about love oh
they hate each other
isn't that amazing people can love each
other and then just hate each other they
call that a love-hate relationship yes
they do i haven't hated that i have a
hate hate with you
feelings mutual yes all right coming up
gun control talks heating up in congress
as the far left demands confiscation
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now